les chéris hier michael ho tram à
laâyoune qu'on aime et était avec nous
dans l'émission america's avait parlé de
morning light son émission qui va faire
sur m6 une émission que j'attends bien
entendu puisque j'aime michael j'adore
ce qu'il fait et hier je lui avais dit
quoi qu'il arrive je regarderai ton
émission
sauf qu'aujourd'hui les programmes sont
tombés et ouais mais michael a été
programmée le 19 mars
et c'est un jeudi aie aie aie jeudi soir
le 19 mars il y a la grande race sera en
direct sur ces 8 et alors on s'appelait
cet après midi on sait comment on va
faire
est-ce qu'on peut changer est ce qu'on
peut trouver des solutions dont les des
solutions de changer parce qu'on est
très très tristes et énervé de se
retrouver en face tous les deux ce que
lui avait envie de regarder répondra
sera moi j'ai envie de regarder
michaël youn donc on sait pas comment on
va faire donc je vous le dis voilà c'est
vrai que c'est on a été on aurait dû se
faire je pense qu'avec m6 et je l'aurais
je leur ai dit je redis on aurait du
sens par les avant bras plus en parle
avant se dire voilà tient est ce que tu
vas voir un truc jeudi soir parce qu'ils
savent que le jeudi soir on a souvent
des prime sur sûreté vite et peut-être
sans parler avant et c'est vrai que ça
nous a voilà ça nous a ça nous as à 12h
à fouiner mois passé pour ça nous a fait
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde aime
bien je joue avec ma dymanique
management ils ont mis jeudi soir et
jeudi soir c'est la guinée et ça a été
la ccva ces questions voilà on va dire
voilà parce que je pense qu'il aurait
cartonné un autre jour malik vraiment
cartonné je pense que c'est un mauvais
jour le jeudi soir et là mickaël c'est
vrai que ça me fait vraiment chier de me
retrouver en face de michael qui est un
super etc c'est idiot droite est dû se
parler avant j'ai vu plein de gens sur
twitter qui rigolait pas ce qu'il disait
hier j'ai quand même dit quoi qu'il
arrive regarderai je perçois sur l'écran
derrière leurs émissions dégoûter tous
les jeudis on a quelque chose que ce
soit bt les cas la raison mais c'est
vrai mais a toujours quelque chose
restons sur le débat mature et le pardon
mais j ai ce que vous français faisant
nettement que tf1 vient vous chercher de
jeudi et que m6 avec une chaîne avec
laquelle vous avez très bonne relation
vient aussi vous cherchez le jeudi à
moins je m'en lave moi moi je pense je
pense que ces essais il savait très bien
qu'on avait un truc c'est franchement
c'est rendre service ni à michael sabia
nous donc c'est ce que c'est
ils savent que le jeudi soir on est en
prime tous les jeudis soir c'est qu'on
est c'est vrai que michael voulait être
un autre jouant michael voulait table
mari soit voilà et ils ont choisi jeudi
soir bonsoir
et une fois que c'est annoncé ya jamais
aucun cas aucune jurisprudence si
l'actuel pdg ma part une édition et
autres mais david une amende autrement
il faut payer
alors voilà je suis à deux doigts de
payer l'amendé non mais je vous jure
ce qu'est ce qu'on fait donc voilà on va
voir mais à priori le 19 mars sauf
vraiment surprise vous aurez donc
michaël youn sur m6 et la grande race
sera sur ses huit en direct merci cyril
qui se serait cassé quelque chose en
tombant dans les marches
voilà ce que je suis dans l'émission de
mikl moi l'air d'accident oui je suis
d'écouteurs du smic elle voulait ma vie
tu es sur la bbc
voilà il a déjà tourné je crois les deux
premières moi le premier les deux
premières avaient tourné ils vont
tourner d'autres mamies ch même pour les
gens parce que je suis sûr que les gens
ils voulaient regarder et la grande
ravine
il a une mission de même je suis un peu
nerveux